Marcia Marcia Marcia maureen McCormick  salsa almost didn't happen sorry my back  turns out the 60 year old barely made it  to the ballroom due to an injury but she  did still managed to get immunity if he  would ask me on Saturday would you be  able to dance on monday probably say  ninety percent now I definitely have  injured something it's either my pelvic  hip or the discs we don't know yet for  sure I he was at Cedars with me all  night just before I am on Wednesday so  she didn't sleep the challenge is still  ahead of us because hopefully tomorrow  we'll get an MRI and we soared what the  problem is and try to fix it because  even coming into the next way just  because of the immunity this is still  whole next week to deal with this is the  case for the next week I'll take it I  did this without the k we were supposed  to be closed